so yesterday attorney general mayor
garland remember this was supposed to be
a legal mind for the ages and he wasn't
just some sort of political hack who
did the law no he was not an eric holder
type he was going to be a non-partisan
unifying figure that's why he was picked
remember some of the alternatives that
joe biden had been looking at were far
more radical publicly facing
than merrick garland was for attorney
general and they've been talking about
doug jones from alabama as the attorney
general of the united states they've
been talking about bringing back some of
the obama holdovers instead joe biden
picked merrick garland specifically
because merrick garland was supposed to
not be a political hack widely respected
almost made the supreme court right
instead it turns out that pretty much
every
left-minded
judicial appointee if given the power of
the attorney general would turn into
merrick garland this seems to be the
case so merrick garland has been a very
highly political attorney general and he
was called in front of the senate
yesterday to talk about how the doj was
targeting parents because remember the
doj put out an entire memo talking about
how they were going to essentially sick
the fbi on parents who had questions
about how school boards were running and
they did so at the behest of a national
school boards association which had
claimed that there was a massive uptick
in violence against school boards
without actually demonstrating that that
was in fact the case
so yesterday merrick island was called
to the hill
and he was asked questions about this
because when the federal government is
called upon by an outside source to
start investigating violence and then on
the basis of no evidence starts to do
that this could have a pretty
significant chilling effect on people
who might want to get involved in say
their local school board if you found
out that the fbi and doj were suddenly
targeting your point of view and giving
you a little bit of extra scrutiny
because they had been told to by your
political opponents might that not be
somewhat chilling so merrick garland was
specifically asked about the fact that
if this really was a pressing law
enforcement issue that required the
intervention of the doj could he name
any specific act of violence that had
led to this large-scale announcement
from the doj here was merrick garland
saying well not so much
best of my recollection i said that the
impetus for the letter
for my memorandum was that letter and
also uh reports um of of this kind of
activity what reports
i said again that at the time that they
were news reports um that had
been published and i think that uh some
of the other senators here have
described some of those news reports and
we've certainly seen subsequently more
news reports and more statements by
board members of threats to kill them
okay so threats of violence okay but but
when cotton asked him specifically about
the memo that the doj put out which
included quote violence threats of
violence as well as harassment and
intimidation garland had no response
because harassment and intimidation are
not quite the same thing as threats of
violence
because it turns out that if somebody
disagrees with you at a school board
meeting that could be considered quote
unquote harassment or intimidation this
is something mike lee pointed out
okay so merrick garland then
admitted that the original letter that
that caused the doj to start looking
into parents did not include acts of
violence in the letter
you didn't investigate the incidents in
the letter did you no
this is the first step this is an
assessment step that comes before
investigations
before you issued your memo you didn't
investigate the incident remember the
memo isn't intended to begin assessments
it is intended and in fact most of the
instance
in the letter were did not involve
threats of violence did they i think
that's correct most of them did not and
they would not be covered by either
federal or state law i agree with that
and they would be protected by the first
amendment
okay so then the question is if you did
not have a pressing need to do this why
did you do this and the answer of course
is that this served the left-leaning
agenda suggesting that school boards
everywhere are doing a wonderful job and
parents who have questions about school
boards are doing a terrible job this led
tom cotton to rip into america garland
telling him he probably should just
resign his job
do you apologize to scott smith and his
15 year old daughter judge
senator anyone whose
child was raped as a most horrific crime
i can imagine and is certainly entitled
and protected by the first amendment to
protest to their school board about that
but he was cited by the school board
association that's fine he's a domestic
terrorist which we now know that letter
and those reports were the basis for
your job
that's wrong judges is shameful
this testimony your directive your
performance is shameful okay that's not
thank god you are not on the supreme
court you should resign in disgrace
judge
okay and of course merrick garland was
very upset because he said well it's not
really the nsba letter that caused us to
do all this it was just kind of the nsba
letter that caused us to do all this
josh haley got in on the act as well the
senator from missouri he he said that
you guys are talking about using the
language of domestic terrorism via the
nsba to apply to parents what are you
doing here
several of my democrat colleagues have
today just today in this hearing
multiple times have compared parents who
show up at school board meetings like mr
smith here have compared them to
criminal rioters you think that's right
you think that a parent who shows up at
a school board meeting who has a
complaint who wants to voice that
complaint and maybe she doesn't use
exactly the right grammar you think
they're akin to criminal writers do you
agree with that i do not and i do not
remember any senator here compare making
that comparison oh really these people
are just like the folks who came here on
january 6th and in the riot at the
capitol
i don't think it was they were referring
to the picture that you're showing there
so then who exactly were they referring
to so here is the thing when it comes to
the application of law via the attorney
general's office when it comes to the
doj the doj has to be
a somewhat
honorable institution bill barr got an
enormous amount of flack when he was
attorney general because the idea from
the left is that he was doing the
bidding of donald trump routinely that
was not true we know many occasions
where bill barr was directly at odds
with donald trump donald trump for
example wanted bill barr he wanted jeff
sessions to investigate hillary clinton
they didn't do that he wanted bill barr
to start initiating investigations of
the election and bill barr wouldn't do
that like this sort of stuff happened
all the time under donald trump can
anyone name a single time where a
democratic president has gone to his a.g
and said i'd like to do x and the ag
said no
see this is the dirty little secret
about the the way that politics work at
the presidential level pretty frequently
when there's a republican president and
he says something untoward the people
around him say you're not allowed to do
that this happened with trump all the
time half of the things that trump
suggested on twitter were then walked
back by his own administration and
people around him said we won't
implement that and then trump just
dropped it but when joe biden says jump
the people around him say how high and
this has some pretty deleterious effects
on americans lives
and to take just another example it is
merrick garland who's been spending his
days cracking down on police departments
around the country while simultaneously
the crime rate's been going up
murder rates have spiked in nearly every
major american city but it was merrick
garland who decided very early on that
he was going to rescind the trump
administration's policies with regard to
consent decrees with regard to local
police departments
it was all the way back in april
that cnbc reported that merrick garland
had rescinded trump-era limits on
consent decrees which the doj had used
to enforce reforms in police departments
accused of widespread misconduct
garland said he would return to the
traditional process in place before
trump's administration imposed sharp
restrictions on the tool garland said in
a memo together we will continue the
department's legacy of promoting the
rule of law protecting the public
working collaboratively with state and
local governmental entities to meet
those end that is not what consent
decrees historically have been under
democratic administrations consent
decrees have been a way to force local
police departments to tell cops not to
do things right these consent decrees
have largely been based on bad evidence
this is certainly the case with the
seattle consent decree under the obama
administration it's been a way to to
cram down particular
diversity-laden viewpoints that have
nothing to do with the reality of
policing
how the law is enforced matters an awful
lot
and this also happens to be the case i
mean merrick garland got rigged over the
coals yesterday for having greenlit a
settlement
with fb former fbi acting director
andrew mccabe you'll remember that andy
mccabe was fired because an inspector
general found that annie mccabe had lied
in testimony like he had lied to the fbi
and he leaked out information that he
was not cleared to leak
and that's according to james comey
and now the justice department agreed to
pay mccabe and his attorneys over 700
thousand dollars
during a senate judiciary committee
oversight hearing senator chuck grassley
expressed outrage over the settlement
calling the move quote beyond incredible
noting that a doj inspector general
review found mccabe to be lying to
investigators on seven separate
occasions
garland's answer quote the mccabe
settlement was a recommendation of the
career lawyers litigating that case
based on their prospects of success in
the case
garland said it involved to claim that
he was not given the amount of time
necessary to respond to allegations the
litigators concluded they needed to
settle the case because of the
likelihood of loss on the merits of the
claim
do you think that on principle if mccabe
had been a strong democrat that that
would have been anything that the doj
decided to settle out
what do you think
and once the doj becomes an overtly
political tool which it is under merit
garland people start to lose trust in
the institutions i mean and again this
this didn't start with him janet reno
was a tool of the clinton administration
going all the way back
but it is worthy of note that this
administration which pledged to be a
bipartisan unifying administration
is basically the soft face of
authoritarianism they're constantly
doing authoritarian things via powers
delegated to them by effectless and
incompetent congress over the course of
decades
and they're just doing what they will
with it
and it's really really ugly
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content